are we doing bomb I tried B I launched
bomb if we manage to do this it will be
a miracle that oh god I forgot your
outfit who me
no I see I don't see you yet oh hey oh
my god is what um oh we have to work
together you have to work together
Oh God what's this oh okay so you see
these screws in the corner oh I think I
have tried this once wait okay I'm
setting that down your thrills that's my
drill that's my drill go get your own
room you knocked over my drill oh no I
know where my arm oh my arm
can you guys see my arm no stop
complaining and get the bomb oh my god
this thing mark can you do the other
side I got this I am struggling with the
drill here got it got it got it here
we're gonna set this up for you kind of
nicely hopefully okay the same working
pan aye it's not going I don't have a
good grip on it oh I hear people yes
you're beeping yeah it's the bomb yeah
oh I think your screws still in there
though I am aware mark you gotta take
the screw out I don't know if you oh oh
I'm sorry that's your so right Wade
you're so right thank you
it's that one over there yeah this one
oh okay yeah
right now watch out I'll get move your
goddamn hand move your frickin way lose
weight move your [ __ ] hand come on
mark I believe it's not College there's
no way okay live your for our twitching
all right I'm gonna leave this drill for
you Wade
here take the fill you got a drill no no
no oh I'll catch that you guys will
attach it I need that drill I am gonna
give it to you do not if you push it
take the goddamn drill take the drill
take it it's yours perfect that one this
one you got a trigger it wait you're not
doing this one let's say here the
trigger is on longest side there we go
oh this is not gonna work right there
you got it
you've got see that right that's good
that's good oh my god you're [ __ ] the
wizard keep going
all right and get this off of there
perfect okay charge
I will just Oh God he was in charge he
was in charge all right well done Bob
yeah proud of you
next step was probably we should have
left I guess that's my bad
running away read the get away from my
drill white no that's fine every time
every time every time every time oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god
pit whoa are you guys ready for how good
I am at this video game yes oh [ __ ] look
at this [ __ ] you've got this so much
better than everyone else here am I on
it you really are all right well my two
are done
how are you idiots doing it's just you
and your
man I got it is it running it's running
it's running right okay good good I got
it it's perfect it's fine a little less
a little less weird why is this like
it's it literally is magnetically
attracted from the circle it is going
everywhere but the screw oh my god oh my
god screws are you seeing this it is
literally going everywhere oh my god oh
my god you could've kept mark I think
you might want to switch hands
oh it's fine it's fine watch this got it
all right oh I'm going that way now what
is it there got it okay
let go the other hand let go let go my
hands are stuck my hands are stuck
together all right there you go there
you go
oh yeah you got this you got this do you
know where of what I have touch it we're
still working on that one screw god it's
me baby
is my baby alright let's get this thing
off there careful careful
I am NOT in charge oh hey my game
crashed so you just hold the lid that's
fine Beach we'll all right read this for
me please
just grasp that all right like oh then
I'll just read it on the table I think
that's fine all right cool good install
toggle switches in position a 1 B 1 C 1
D 2 e 2 say that again
install toggle switches in position a1
b1 c1 a we - e - yeah
[Music]
man somebody took too long doing their
screws huh
whenever you guys are able to join hello
oh I'm inside someone Oh No oh god I see
eyeballs why did the bomb explode okay
well holy nightmare fuel in front of
them for me yeah I have a button don't
worry about it it's fine
wait I'm gonna help you mark I'm gonna
help I got I got I got I got I got I did
I did my part
perfect nailed it got it we are so good
did you uh did you want that back no no
no you it's good day alright alright Bob
let's do this am i screwing not yet
right there alright bad boy up okay you
got it I got it
we look together oh there's a button or
a button seems to be call hole oh
alright just gonna move my arm let you
guys are blocking the bomb Dorian
oh wait Russian bomb type suka breath
haha I use the bad words alright cool
good who wants to grab the paper and not
blow us up
usually has it alright yeah cuz your
face I got it I got it
perfect so tell guys right wait what it
says install toggle switches and
positions a1 that's that the ones done
here by Mac I got this I got the toggles
they were b2 or wire oh my god am i
touching that you were touching
why're but it's fine it didn't come out
that son yeah I think so yeah that's
good too
there we go see one oh I did see one
yeah yeah I feel like you should have
been doing the toggles since I'm on your
side
yeah yeah maybe my bad for for
volunteering for that yeah it's good I
blame everyone else but me get ready to
receive the glory that wait wait god
wait god damn it wait oh god your left
hand that's not me Bob
oh I am the best I think I'm on it boom
yeah you're doing it you're doing it
you're doing it you're doing it you're
doing it okay done we're so good careful
careful careful careful
all right install toggle switches and
positions a 1 B 2 C 2 you've got this we
got this wait you gotta slide this a
little bit right perfect I love it I
love okay so what about the read the
rest wait what does it say was it say a
1 B 2 C 2 D 1 e 2 okay so a 1 Huggle it
you knocked a 1 up to a 2 I hope I don't
want to do the switches sometimes the
toggle you see whether you do the
switches switches but then we don't get
anything done do we
well no guess not interesting angle oh
not that way well guys I lost my drill
frames frames my frames were all over
the place man my frames no no I could so
okay why can't I grab you know oh no you
need another drill I might need a drill
this might be salvageable no it's out of
my reach okay here giving you a drill
there it's right there just there you go
yeah this will work
I mean just oh yeah I'm gonna keep this
one just in case we need it
yeah probably good good good good choice
all right listen I got go baths real
quick you guys stay here this I'll be
right back
don't blow it
screw you drill screw and then my little
thingies around Oh No Oh God Bob what oh
dear I I just pushed my drill off the
table and it touched him he died I just
pushed the drill off the day why am i
dead why am i dead I pushed my drill off
the table and it landed on you and you
die why am i right mark you got that
yeah I got that yeah thanks yeah okay
I'll read the instructions cuz I got a
good view of you toggle the switches I
don't want it's perfect they're all one
they all need to go to one one for every
one of them that's good oh yeah hey oh
hey Mac it went to two briefly I think
you should alternate you should never
try to pull a switch oh we should poop
them yeah just like always pushing and I
think that's the only way to make it
happen I believe we can get this I
believe we have very little belief but I
will try you so close just up and tour
me oh god I was drooling you Bob I'm so
sorry
nice nice nice nice done okay all right
let's get dish out of here all right one
of the toggles I'm ready to push alright
so a one swoop good
I gotta go b1 lower a little lower a
little oh yeah you're good you're good
give it a little Boop perfect dunt dunt
ploy ploy so oh god boys boys just oh
that's a bet this is d2 so this is easy
with me do it to it okay we've done done
done done done okay
remove fuse see we get the paper the
paper I won't try and grab the paper
very delicately okay just
my game crashed and it did that oh wow
that's the closest I've ever come to the
defusing that was sad we were doing
great but that just means we'll do
better next time
yeah we've got this almost why do you
slide this away just do your left there
you go get that yeah Bob your hand is
holding it down what is happening yeah
Bob why is it beeping I don't know
what's a beeping things are happening
before we're not dead oh my god wait
careful oh my god Jesus croquet yep Minh
that's a totally uses out okay I'm just
gonna start beeping numbers I guess to
see to remove all the fuses yeah it's
fine it's fine it's fine I gotta just
just rip these bad boys out right it
said remove all the fuses it said yeah
yeah I did ok a 2 B 2 C 2 so it's 2 2 2
1 1 is not a good sound but I feel like
we're doing all right you got day 2
you're working on it there you go there
you go that's lined up I think we've no
2 2 B 2 2 2 1 1 I think somehow we've
bugged it I don't know how yeah ok ok so
now remove all red wires oh my god so
the one way I silly knocked off is
supposed to be of yeah okay Wade yeah
you're gonna punch in a code okay okay
all right just okay okay I have two more
red wires to get Wade there's a screw
there there's a screen you're right just
be very careful I'm going to gently
that's fine
got it okay you're gonna punch in this
code - Oh Bob set the knob to eight set
the knob to eight what the [ __ ] out of
wood if you think I am too
I'll get you okay it's not showing up a
number so let's set the knob to eight
nice I think we got this we just do one
good try all right all right I'm gonna
just take care of this because be able
to get it before move your hands please
okay a to be one well those are both you
then okay drifted it god damn own self
it's okay
forget you good at this we're getting
good I'm gonna like hide my hand down
here and just leave it wait what you
doing bud my right arm it's so much
better than the left one looks like
you're twisted by way too hello welcome
to my side we're gonna run out time
okay guys all right okay good job on the
table I didn't do that I didn't do that
I didn't do that my hands on the table
out of the way okay record time we're
gonna get this rag up down over here
real just gonna lids away let is safely
away okay this is not coming back okay
oh my god you pulled out a fuse but I
think it's one of the one you're
supposed to pull out okay you gotta
remove fuses B and D we got D already
toggle switches are a 1 B 1 C 1 D we'll
all ones except for E good good Bob good
I have a strategy for the wires it's you
just squish them with your thumb okay my
left arm is not cooperating careful
careful careful careful
you're good you're so good you're so
good don't touch the button don't touch
cool yes take that wires push a toward
one for me I guess that's me like marks
really good enough
you guys got this these high-stakes
action here so can I go ahead and start
pressing the other ones we're through
these in order no you don't have them in
order but let me just get this push them
all you got it you got it you're good
you're good you're good you're good
you're good you're good
okay moving no way now oh wait it's bush
go away it's footy one see one bomb I
thought you were implying that wasn't
having to do a lot of these not to alarm
you guys we have a minute and 38 seconds
yeah you've got it done done done Duncan
leaving okay all right those are done
okay whose be do I have to do B yeah you
have to do B what is the namibian knob
knob knob - oh my god huh oh my god oh
my god oh my god well why it's going the
wrong way your thumbs hitting it No whoa
Bob I think it's you took too long to
move the knob and it'll blow up as soon
as you get it to do okay I think that's
what happens bmd out the buttons are 9 3
2 - dude Wade we're dead no no no no do
the buttons and let's save the fuse for
the save the but the thingy for last
ok I'm three - I think you have to do
that way of course I do
mark you're really just watching yeah I
can't see my above three but you did it
Ethan you pushed it Oh three times I
think it's not coming up in the numbers
because we're dead I'm practicing anyway
no does it - that's [ __ ] oh there's the
numbers yeah I think it's like if you
don't get that knob in in like ten
seconds to the right number it'll it'll
be a bomb yeah you're so host come on
there ya go away delicately oh god oh my
god oh my god
oh thank god careful oh oh I'm gonna
take this okay as well what are the
fluid knobs
good question knobs knob no no a 1 B 2 C
2 D 2 so 8 1 and eat wanna go on ones
that are one okay okay 1 2 2 2 1
I go for a 1 right now so you have to do
all except for C I think Bob hmm arm
please just chill there she it literally
was pushing on it and then slid to the
side went to the other side and then you
ain't it really hard
it's unpossible if I kill one here it's
not my fault I lived in a way fuses are
seaso all the only grabs I don't grab it
over the fuses just grab like yes just
somewhere nice initial parts of this is
the last try this is my drill that
sounds like excuses too much my drill
frames do you need frames frames tell me
frames tell me all right no matter what
can you can you do this screw with your
hand who I am leaving this world my
people need me this is the last one
guys I [ __ ] did it
I've shown two jobs here wait why do you
take the ones by my side nothing for the
rest of the [ __ ] look how fast we did
it all right guys four minutes wow
that's a lot of minutes he'll get out
here there we go it's gone all right
careful wait don't drop that low when
you grab it
okay you got oh good okay good good good
you want that just like just let it go
let go you got it wait put your arm
under the table I believe in you okay
all right so 2 2 1 1 2 2 2 ok so I'm on
the first one I got the a 2 right
yeah what's the knob mark the knob is
one very close my arm is veering stop
fearing it all right one almost there
and you're so close it's almost a 1 on
it it's not there it'll turn green when
it's there okay there we go b2 are you
all ready for me to do B - wait are you
still cooking done done got that one
done okay - - what goes the rest of it -
2 1 1 2 got it that clicked saw 2 1 1 2
so both of these go so I do see one
sorry sorry got him okay okay so I just
need to do see one and we're yet with
that yep mm-hmm
Wade you need fuses C and D got it done
all blue wires all blue wires okay gutsy
I'm out out of your way as much as I can
physically be 55 seconds wait wait for
the wires are then wait for the wires
one more wire
okay 300 n3v line
[Music]
five five oh god is this five yeah 5
I swore
1:8
six three two
[Laughter]
my god trying so hard not to yell at you
to go faster oh my god Oh awesome we did
it oh my god I can't believe it
you kidding me I didn't do any you were
you were our fearless leader right right
yeah the instructions clearly in
screaming anyone mmm if that doesn't get
me to 2 million YouTube subscribers I
don't know what will
[Music]
you